ok I think we're live now okay I'm gonna
send you this in the chat there you go
you will keep an eye on the chat for me
and make sure the video looks good
because I need a second monitor and I
don't have one yet which which by the
way I need to hold on the same guys
we're trying to get everything sorted
out make sure my see I can settings
there we go hopefully that looks it's
weird I don't know all right looks like
Jesus is getting ready to come to my
room but her my apartment but whatever
ok so anyway so looks like it's just me
and Dave on the weekly pool today Sal is
somewhere where there's no internet
whatsoever and then he said he had a
meeting with somebody so I guess what we
talking about the house of him what do
you mean
were you drunk
my whole screen is in a corner of my
screen
huh
that's interesting
hmm yep just us because everybody else
bailed out I guess one off the bat ask
the people in the chat if they have any
questions because i figured to be maybe
an awesome session also chance to like
answer questions as subscribers have and
they're like fans of us have of me
Vinnie and Sal even though they both
bailed out on us oh my god Dave Oh Margo
but all right so you finished reading
the house with him ok so what do you
think of it
you gotta liven it up Dave we're live
man you got out you got to pep it up all
right
you tour the x-men companion to the
house of him
oh ok but you meant like you read like
the main house of m storyline though ok
ok
see that was a thing for me like like I
loved the story of the House of M like I
thought it was really really interesting
because the whole idea of having some
character that would warp reality and
effectively like give everybody what
they wanted I thought was really like it
was it was pretty interesting to me but
the way it played out like it wasn't
like there was trouble in paradise
basically because you had like dr. doom
doing his whole thing you know and you
had him trying to like overthrow Magneto
and trying to establish himself as the
head of I guess all of mutant kind and I
thought that there were some really cool
undercurrents to the story but in the
end I mean you just got like the super
powerful chick that warps reality and
have you read decimation you know what
happens after okay they can't hear you
well
alright
this is a work in progress people i have
never live streamed on using skype
before alright
I'm trying to figure out how to do this
let's try that
ok
good people here you know well probably
in a few seconds
like they can't hear you at all or they
can barely hear you
well talk with the people in the chat
what kind of questions are they asking
all at least I'll try to answer some of
the questions they have while we're
waiting 20
now you're coming through I can hear you
fine the problem is on my end I think
Oh
that's weird man
well
I don't know I don't know
well this stream certainly turned out to
be some of the fantastic isn't it well I
God can't get our [ __ ] together people
can't hear hag basically asked me your
mobile questions and I will answer them
probably original sin for right now but
it's really the only one that I'm
reading
oh my god
well as soon as I get this audio figured
out all the old answer that question no
one can hear you talking at all there's
no audio on Dave's then
huh
I don't know I don't think it has
anything to do with the stream
yeah that's what I'm trying to figure
out
all right hold on them hold on one
second guys we're going to see if we can
fix this
Oh
place of the man hey how's it goin if
not we might have to postpone this
terrible podcast until next week I'm not
gonna be here oh my god we cannot get
you and sal and the same time I swear to
god man well that's good though because
at least you have a third then yeah well
we're gonna be at my surgery either that
or like we're gonna do it like way later
at night and I'm probably going to be
zoned out on anesthesia and pain killers
you want to just try to restart
everything I don't think that's a
problem I just like we did oh yes
this truce tipster it's like
it's called Doug juice actually
and you do it in your vaping man does
everybody in Fayette think if you love
cigarettes it was gonna happen but like
they can hear me now oh they can hear
you know well at least I can hear me in
the stream now can everybody hear Dave
all right now apparently i'm way too
loud I'll fix that on my end oh really
okay okay guys does Dave sound better
now you probably will hear in the next
few seconds or so we'll get it sorted
out man we'll get it sorted out
alright
yeah says now will did did too for a
second too loud
I think I think we just have to wait for
the stream to catch up yeah yeah the
stream is gonna be behind my a few
seconds by five or ten seconds
what's so funny well it's just like
we're we're talking and we figured out
that we fixed the issue but the whole
streams like what everybody just
screaming it's too loud oh my god Rob
get your [ __ ] together man I cared you a
little people are saying like damn it
Rob oh my god all right so I think now
hashtag babe has changed the struggle
the struggle is real all right so um
since we had the audio issues what
what's your favorite running currently
and Marvel Winkley original scent for
right now like original sin is the only
one that's really running that I'm
reading but original sin is not very
good where they're doing it right now
but I think it's the direction they're
going in like they made nick fury old
all that kind of stuff it's it's kind of
silly like like one of the things that
will be talking about during my Franklin
Richards videos will be talking about
the Franklin Richards paradox you know
with Franklin Richards paradoxes no well
no you were talking about it before I
think it's it's where we think that
Franklin Richards wills everybody to be
young just because he doesn't want
anybody to age yeah that's basically it
like Franklin Richards is controlling
the entire university entire Marvel
Universe and it's it's it's weird like
like like I said like we'll be talking
about this ring finger Richards more in
death but more or less like Franklin
Richard shows up in Marvel Comics and
for like the first 20 or 30 years that
he's a Marvel Comics it just doesn't
really do a whole lot I mean
becomes avatar at some point where he
makes itself this old price like dude
you know and it's it's weird like his
powers are like flare up and something
will happen and then they'll die down
and it becomes part of power pack and
uses his powers for a little while and
then that goes away and then it's like
it's the 90s and the 2000s and it's
character because we're prominent but
from the time that he's first introduced
to Marvel Comics up until the present
day my characters don't really age some
characters did Nick Fury got older but
most characters don't age and so the
question here or the argument that
people make is that Franklin Richards is
willing everybody to be young is the
audio better and the stream yeah
nobody's complaining anymore cuz
everybody left oh um just came in Dave
you are still a bit loud compared to rob
but it's not as bad okay okay do you
want to lower down on your in a little
bit and we'll see if that yeah let's do
that let's see if it works I I've
lowered it down about twenty percent
okay hopefully that sounds a whole lot
better in the stream oh yeah but
Franklin Richards is really cool
character model comics because the
problem with a character like Franklin
Richards like I said well well don't
worry guys we will we're going to do
like a 25 30 minute long video on
franklin richards but the problem when
it comes to franklin richards in marvel
comics is you can't do a whole lot with
this character i mean when you have the
character they can warp reality and fix
anything by snapping his fingers what
can you really do with him I mean now he
be yeah he becomes really cool and
there's some really cool stuff that
happens with him later on but it's like
the adult Franklin Richards so when we
get into like the Future Foundation and
we get into the Fantastic Four and Reed
Richards that are then there's like an
infinite number of him and they all meet
in like this weird location like this
nexus kind of place and there's like an
infinite version infinite number of
versions of him I don't think we see
like an infinite number but i think
there's there's like a whole ton of
versions of them they all meet together
and they all try to fix the fix every
problem i mean it's it's
you get into some really weird and wild
stuff and franklin richards becomes more
important later on especially when he
makes Galactus is Harold but in the end
like he's still a character that you
just can't do a whole lot with because
how many it's like the Scarlet Witch the
Scarlet Witch was a character who was
cool when all she could do was do hexes
and she could do magic on people and she
can make people do stuff or she could
you know Ben things in her will or in
her favor or something like that and all
of a sudden she goes crazy after
Avengers disassembled she works reality
makes the House of M changes it back and
all the mutants are gone so her
character is one of these characters
where you can only do so much with her
because if a person can warp reality
then what would be the use for them if
they can fix any problem anywhere any
time doing just simply thinking about
fixing it you know it's it's one of
those silly concepts you want me oh yeah
but I also think that that balances her
character and it gave them a good reason
to do House of M yeah I mean it it's one
of those things where a character that's
like that almost has to be crazy because
their powers of our that that really she
doesn't even realize what reality is
anymore because she has those abilities
yeah well she can think anything into
existence that was the thing so that's
what made her so estimator so dangerous
because when the house of him first
started when you had the very beginnings
like issue number imma member if it was
the pre luter four was actually issue
number one but when Xavier called a
meeting of the Avengers the x-men and a
few superheroes here and there they were
gonna kill her I think that was that was
zero issue okay ya Xavier wanted a
killer I mean you had like Cyclops who
is like there's no way we can do this
and Captain America so there has to be
another way but Xavier and Doctor
Strange were like this chicks warping
reality and she's going insane there may
be there may come a point where she can
change things and we can't there's no
way to change it back because she's just
gone crazy so with a character like that
there's the house of him what his bat
was about as far as you could go with
the Scarlet Witch that was that was
really it and that's that's the thing
that I'm interested in when it comes to
Marvel Cinematic Universe are they going
to make her a character like she is in
the comics because in the comics she had
like all these crappy life experiences
like she was almost burned alive because
she used her powers out in public and
all different kinds of stuff and when it
came to like the shards of Mephisto and
her believing that she had kids even
though it didn't really exist her
character just became more and more
insane as time went on and just led up
to this so you had a ventures
disassembled did you ever read Avengers
disassembled I have that in the mail
right now ok I won't ruin it for you but
you have the Avengers disassembled info
huh I've said before that I don't mind
things getting ruined but you might ruin
things for them and that might piss them
off that's like you do all the time ask
him if they care if I go we're Avengers
disassembled but keep in mind Benny is
gonna do Avengers disassembled on his
channel too so we're not going to go
like we won't go really in depth because
he I think you'll do a really good video
on it it'll be after guardians of the
galaxy month though so we're talking
about probably September before he
doesn't uh August before he does it but
we'll see what's up are you talking then
the chat mm-hmm why I don't know you
told me to ask him why can't you just
like you could just block it if I
could've asked them unless I can't hear
you then you're like Dave Dave a scone
okay do you guys care about Avengers
disassembled I mean if they're ready go
over and I'll go over it if they don't
want me to go over then I won't go over
it but yeah it's an interesting story
but the Avengers disassembled is like a
necessity to understand what goes on in
the house of em that's why I'm waiting
until bet he does Avengers disassembled
before i do House of M because then
it'll just be like oh my god the Scarlet
Witch is just nuts one day no one really
understands yeah I'm up to how it
happened but alright so what do you
think like do you think that the marvel
cinematic universe is going to make the
Scarlet Witch like progressively insane
i I don't know I think so I mean the
Cinematic Universe is already gather
kind of in like a crazy padded room yeah
so I mean I think she's already insane I
just don't know if she's powerful enough
to do anything with her powers yet well
I don't know see that's the thing like
we only have a glimpse of her so I don't
know if it's that she's crazy or that
she's just developed her abilities and
she's figuring them out but like the
Scarlet Witch had this upbringing we're
like her and quick civil were basically
raised on their own they basically like
took care of themselves for a huge
portion of their lives I mean they're
raised by the maximize for a while and
then she use her powers and blew up the
house and so they didn't they ran off
and for the most part they were just
teaching themselves what they needed to
know as they went along and in they
encountered Magneto and magneto instills
his insane ideologies and the two of
them and screws up their lives and so
now they move forward with that they
eventually become superheroes I joined
the Avengers and she has all these weird
experiences but throughout all this like
her mind is just slowly being screwed up
and slowly being warped and then
eventually it all just comes two comes
to a head with the house of him
storyline all right do you think that
what they did at the end of house of
them was a good idea where they
basically reversed everything or no um
were they basically there was they
removed all the mutants I think it was a
good idea because there was too many
mutants yeah I think that was the reason
for this event is that there were too
many mutants and they had to get rid of
some and then I don't I haven't read too
far after like I've read the the
decimation book for a couple different
characters but I haven't read you know
anything directly after this event so I
don't know if they kept it that way I
think they did yeah oh I was reading arm
there was another x-men book that came
right afterwards that centered around
rogue in a couple a couple other x-men
like a team that they put together and I
know they were talking about a little
bit how it how it hurt to have so few
mutants on earth when there was like
almost a million yeah so okay so what
we're gonna do in this
gases we're gonna do a Marvel explained
a Marvel explained in this podcast so
all right so you've got the House of M
event and and guys in the in the chat
like I'm gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of the
house of m and all this stuff coming up
but you know it's cool and it'll make
for it'll make for a cool topic during
this podcast so what you have is you
have the House of M event you have the
Scarlet Witch goes nuts warps reality
gives people a future where r gives
people a reality where for the most part
they get everything they want like ms
marvel is recognized as the greatest
superhero in the world and that's her
fulfilling her desire to be accepted you
have magneto who was at the very top the
peak of all of mutant cotton and that
gives him what he wants because he
always wanted a future where mutants
were basically the ones running the show
and didn't have to live in fear from
humanity but he had no real concern for
humanity itself which is the reason why
humanity is being treated so harshly and
in such a terrible way during the House
of M event and then you got other
characters so on and so forth and you've
got like Wolverine who still remembers
both things you got Leila Miller that
wakes people up you know awakening them
or whatever it is they call it and the
anything what are people saying um
people are saying could you give guys
give your thoughts on Children's Crusade
I've never heard of that and another
year person guard 55 rx1 asked you if
you could do a Marvel explained
eventually on the runways yeah Lamar
will explain on the runaways the best
people want yeah I'll do you want to
explain on the runaways but anyway so
you have this house of them event it
comes to an end the scarlet witch's
final words the most infamous final were
some of the most infamous final words of
Marvel Comics right before she changes
everything back she says no more mutants
so bam reality goes back to normal
followed up immediately by decimation
and decimation is basically mutant kind
in panic mode they're running around
they're freaking out the whole world has
realized that there are basically no
more mutants left so then you turn over
to the office of national emergency one
and so that's why like when you see like
one sentinels that's what those are the
office of national emergency
signals you have all this craziness
going on we're mutants are now basically
like these refugees they're running
they're trying to escape people that are
persecuting them more so than before
because a lot of people like it like a
lot of groups like friends of humanity
and so on see this as a chance to
eliminate meet and confer face of the
planet forever because they're seasoned
exactly easy pickings are so few of them
so you basically have the Xavier
Institute being turned into like this
refugee camp for mutants and that's
where we pick up with civil war civil
war takes place the same time as
decimation and that's why the x-men have
virtually nothing to do with civil war
because they're trying to get their own
stuff figured out that's why it was a
big deal when x-force broken and
liberated like a whole ton of mutants
from the Xavier Institute because
there's so few of them left and so
that's why you see Cyclops and Iceman
all those guys trying to round up the
mutants that have been liberated by
x-force because they want to make sure
that mutants aren't eradicated entirely
after the House of M you have an event
called the son of him and that actually
revolves around Quicksilver and what
Quicksilver does is he tries to rekindle
his relationship with crystal who was
one of the Inhumans and they were on
again off again for a while and she had
actually spent some time with Johnny
Storm as well and so on and so forth but
i believe that Quicksilver and crystal
had a child together but Quicksilver
goes to the inhuman threshold the
inhuman place wherever it is that
they're hanging out on the birth are on
the blue side of the moon right now or
if they're actually still on the planet
Earth but whatever it is he goes to the
goes to the Inhumans and then he
encounters a future version of himself
that had used the the Terrigen crystals
to enhance his abilities and is actually
able to travel into the pute like travel
through time and as future self tells
them something I kind of what it is but
anyway what the Sun when a Quicksilver
does is he takes the the Terrigen
crystals and he steals them and then he
gives his daughter abilities she wakes
up her abilities and she actually has
the power to see people's intentions
because the color will change by people
i think you have negative intentions
will turn red people
they have positive attention to turn
green and people don't care like yellow
or something I like reveals that
everybody here knows this dot no he did
will help keep that he he does it to
everybody but not to everybody to a
handful of people what he does as he
goes to Genosha and Genosha no I mean I
mean his daughters powers no no his
daughter to savers or just confined to
her okay yeah only see only she can do
that um so he goes to Genosha and I
don't know if you follow the event with
Cassandra Nova where she was she was
just great she was like a version of
Xavier so like that i can remember her
exactly but she had used the one
sentinels to Massacre like 16 million
mutants in Genosha so even before yeah
like oh yeah I heard about that yeah so
like both India and the house of them
like meetings had already been totally
ravaged and so while there's really no
more mutants there anymore there really
weren't a whole lot there to begin with
in the first place but what he does is
he he enlists like several mutants so
he's basically going to use these
Terrigen crystals on and says I can give
you your powers back the first person he
does it with is Callisto and Callisto
was the leader of the Morlocks for time
and she has like enhanced abilities and
enhanced senses and so on and so forth
um it puts her senses into overdrive and
she starts going crazy like it starts
raining and the rain feels like needles
on her skin because her skin is like a
hundred times more sensitive than it had
been before and so basically like the
son of a Quicksilver just screws up
entirely he tries to give people their
powers back using the Terrigen crystals
it gives them their powers back times a
hundred or something along those lines
and makes like a lot of people go crazy
and in fact Callisto's mind i think is
shut down or something's done where she
basically like shuts down entirely and
magneto takes her away and of course she
chastises Quicksilver so and so forth
all right after the House of M after
decimation after all that stuff there's
no more mutants being born there are no
more mutants in existence and the
question that was asked by Hank Pam at
the end of house of him
is what happened all the powers like the
powers had to have gone somewhere
something had to have happened yeah so
we eventually see like this energy
flying like this this this red energy
ring like flying around the planet or
something like that is when the house
like the house of m final issue of the
prologue or whatever epilogue whatever
it is comes to an end but we ended up in
countering this guy called Zorn XOR in
and i can't remember i think it's
magneto but i think was a guy before him
but basically this was a person that had
all the powers that had previously
existed or something like that i can't
remember but um anyway on top of that
you have hope summers now do you know
who hope summers is yes she's the one
who takes on the Phoenix force in AVX
right yeah well the Finnish force gets
split around two but when when marvel
announced hope summers it was a big deal
because the question was is hope summers
going to be the new Jean Grey like
people thought that the gene guard was
gonna be reborn basically because Hope
Summers was going to look exactly like
her she was going to have red hair she
was going to be a harbinger for the
Phoenix force so on and so forth and so
a lot of people thought that Jean Grey
was going to make a return to marvel
comics so you have this point in time in
which a mutant is born when the mutant
is born it blows up cerebro or cerebral
thing at the time is what it was called
because I just can't handle the amount
of information that's coming in at 11
given time it wakes up apocalypse like
she watchin apocalypse out of a dead
sleep and like all these events start
started happening so the x-men travel to
Alaska I think where she was being born
at and find the entire city's been
destroyed and most everybody is dead
come to find out you have William
Stryker and his purifiers you know about
William Stryker yeah okay well he's a
big part of the x-men movies and in
weapon acts and also it's Tom in the
comics William Stryker was not a
military guy but he was not he was out
in the military and the comics William
strikers a reverend he's a preacher
and he's crowd or another yeah yeah he's
crazy he thinks it's his mission from
God to kill mutants and he goes back a
long time like he goes back to nineteen
eighty-two chris claremont run of x-men
i think but he's been around for a long
long time he was he was the major focal
point and the x-men story man loves God
kills which i think is what x-men number
two or number three was based off of but
in the event you have the purifiers and
the purifiers are like these
paramilitary guys that follow William
Stryker with his ideologies no matter
what it is he says and so you have all
these people that are hunting for Hope
Summers you have sinister I think who
made Predator X which is like this
crazy-looking beast animal that can
either absorb or is immune to the powers
of almost everybody you have William
Stryker and its purifiers and you have
the x-men and I can't remember if you
have another group it might be senators
forces but everybody is trying to find
hope summers everybody's trying to get
this this kid it's the first person born
since M day and from what Marvel is
really explained to us she's like this
stupid powerful character alright that
kicks off Messiah Complex and you have
all these events going on we have
basically this cat-and-mouse game
eventually we learn that cable was the
one that got her that picked her up and
cables trying to keep her safe keep her
from being a keeper from being killed
his rationale like a member off top my
head I know Bishop is trying to find her
because Bishop believes that she's the
one that's going to cause his timeline
and she's going to be the one that that
kills them in humans do you know that
bishops timeline have you heard about
that I haven't heard about it but I know
it exists because he has to be traveling
back in time for some reason right like
that that's his like how things are
supposed to happen timeline yeah oh that
right yeah are people that Chad asking
me anything do they want me to keep
going or that's it woman answer cuz I
want to keep talking about something
don't care about
um they want you to do an x-force
explained it looks like uh it looks like
they're talking with each other a little
bit Cassandra Nova was Xavier's twin
sister that he killed in the womb that's
what it was I could remember how I was
taught in to Xavier the comments are no
longer automatically updating on my end
according to this guy that just has
symbols for his name cyborg so I bet
it's all spelled in like weird like text
I want to make sure the streams okay
yeah it streams good and everything yeah
it's automatically updating on my end
yeah um alright so bishops timeline is
is really really interesting in the
realm of Marvel Comics so Bishop comes
from a timeline that's very similar to
the days of future past alright and I
think that's I don't know if Fox got
that confused or Fox screwed up or Fox
just watched x-mini animated series and
said let's do any of that Days of Future
past which was really cool though it was
it was a cool two-part episode but my
favorite episode from action in the
animated series was actually one man's
worth because the whole conflict in the
beginning was really really cool but
Bishop comes from a timeline that's
similar to the days of future past and
that in the past some kind of event
occurred that kicked off the whole
Sentinel program being rebooted and just
like it happened in Days of Future past
the Sentinels began writing their own
programming basically and they reason
they had to enslave both humans and
mutants because mutants our version of
humans and all of them are threat and so
on and so forth and yada yada yada all
right the difference here is that in the
bishop timeline they had an event called
the summers rebellion and that was when
humans and mutants rose up and over
through the whole Sentinel threat
now along the way or I guess after this
is over you have Bishop joining
something called the excess e which is
the Xavier security and foresters or
something like that I can't remember but
the whole reason why this was
established why the excess II was
established and that's where he's
wearing that suit another gray and red
suit that people are most familiar with
the whole reason why this was
established was because after the humans
and mutants overthrew the Sentinels
they're still had to be a way to keep
mutants in check they were always going
to be rogue mutants bad guys and so on
and so forth and so the mutants wanted
to be policed themselves they wanted to
police their own people they didn't want
humans going after them because one
humans would know how to do how to deal
with them into humans would be much more
harsh than they needed to be because
there was still a lot of hatred by
humans against mutants because in their
eyes the the mutants were the ones that
caused this whole timeline in the first
place and so you have Bishop who's part
of the excess II he's initially avidly
against them and then he encounters
somebody I can't remember who it is and
this individual like spurs him on to
become part of the excess see and then
that's compounded by the fact that his
grandmother I think would tell him
stories about the x-men back when the
x-men were you know hard like an active
member of society and before they were
eradicated and so on and so forth so
anyway he joins the xse his sister char
joins the xse she ends up becoming his
boss some stuff happened she becomes as
kind of like powers vampires like that I
can't remember but he ends up having a
killer but he also is chasing after her
boyfriend at the time Trevor Fitzroy and
Trevor Fitzroy jumps back into the past
and the fence happened I can't what it
is but any event this leads Bishop back
to the main earth-616 timeline alright
this is the 1990s of Marvel Comics all
right this is 20-something years ago
alright fast forward to right after the
House of M Bishop realizes that Hope
Summers is the one that destroyed a
million humans in this timeline or
believes that's the case anyway and so
his goal his effort is basically
tracking her down and trying to kill her
that's all he's trying to do and so you
basically had this cat and mouse game
going on where you have Bishop jumping
through time chasing after cable and
Hope Summers who were jumping through
time and they're both trying to elude
yeah bishop entirely in addition to this
you have apocalypse and apocalypse has
reawakened himself he's or he is he's a
he's awakened again after the whole
aftermath of the House of M event and
hope summers and so on and so forth and
he actually offers his blood like he
shows up at the Xavier Institute it
offers his blood saying it'll give
people their powers back or something
like that and they yell out of mean they
kick him out and of course he goes into
hiding again but we have like like a
whole like multitude of crazy things
going on involving the x-men in Marvel
Comics after the House of M because you
have these people that are trying to
protect what's left the 198 which is the
198 mutants that are left you have
apocalypse is trying to reassert himself
as the dominant figure in in all of
society you have Bishop and that's
chasing after cable and hope summers you
have hope summers who could either be
the Messiah or I think model says she
could be the Messiah or she could tread
on the graves of a million people are
something like that which was them
saying that she's the one that can cause
bishops timeline um we don't know what
road she's going to take is entirely
possible that she could become this
crazy person like she she she's the
center of a storyline called the twelve
lights I think which is where she finds
these twelve individuals and wakes up
their dormant powers or their power to
actually I think may have already been
manifesting but she like brave basically
like brings these individuals into the
fold um in Hope Summers becomes a pretty
powerful character in Marvel Comics like
she's I think Lissa is an Omega level
character she can copy the abilities of
anybody that she comes across she can
like use their powers she can choose a
harbinger for the Phoenix force she's a
really really really strong character
but the question is what's the long
picture here like what's the long haul
here and this is what's really
interesting when it comes to Marvel
Comics people look at like the days of
future past on one like one person has
sent me a message actually on YouTube
and asked me you know about the Civil
War of then and the days of future past
and the question they asked is what was
the point of the days of future past if
it was going to happen anyway because
they look at the events like Civil War
and stuff like that when it comes to
like these alternate timelines in Marvel
Comics and even now they still talk
about days if you
pass and whatnot but when it comes to
these alternate timelines of Marvel
Comics it doesn't mean that these
timelines are never going to happen that
doesn't mean they can never take place
in the days of future past comic Kitty
Pryde went into the past and she stopped
the assassination of Senator Robert
Kelly more mctaggart and Charles Xavier
but it doesn't mean that there's no
event that could happen later on down
the line that could cause the days of
future past to happen it just means that
that particular instance was stopped and
the days of future past maybe we'll have
may very well have been postponed so
just because Bishop is trying to stop
hope summers and for all as we can tell
has failed doing so doesn't mean that
bishops timeline won't come to fruition
just because Hope Summers is for the
most part of superhero at this point in
time of Marvel Comics doesn't mean that
she will not end up killing 1 million
humans because maybe her powers run amok
maybe she goes crazy maybe she loses
control of them temporarily like we
don't know what it was that led to the
circumstances that caused her to kill a
million humans all we know is she did
and it started the whole you know
bishops online so it's really
interesting when you look at all these
comics because you see Marvel pointing
to a vincit took place in the 1990s and
saying this could still happen the days
of us could still take place and Marvel
could very well end up you know I guess
producing like this Days of Future past
time line that will eventually be
thwarted it's really weird the way they
do stuff what are marvelous thinking
that far in advance I would doubt it but
it doesn't mean that those those kind of
things aren't like a possibility so it
looks like there's a couple things we
have to discuss I know I want to discuss
at least one of these things um but uh
everybody seems to want us to talk about
female Thor how they're changing forward
to a female and how Falcon is going to
take over for Captain America okay I
don't know anything about Captain Falcon
America up there about a half alcon
America about it was just announced last
night on The Daily Show yeah i don't
know i hit it was but I somebody use a
big shot like organizer
the Marvel Cinematic Universe said hey
we're gonna we're gonna have Falcon take
over for Captain America one when Evans
wants completely out okay so that we
have to speculate about but I think it'd
be fun so all right yeah well it I think
it's going to happen I think it's all
their will I'm letting it it'll be fun
to speculate like how it'll happen yeah
but um all right so the whole female
Thor thing all right people have been
blowing up my whole YouTube page with
this for like days ever since Marvel
came out and announced it all right no
one knows what's going on I'm gonna get
there some source material layer there's
some information there we don't know
this character's backstory all we know
is this Thor as we know him the guy Thor
is not able to wield Thor's hammer
anymore he's not able to wield Mjolnir
anymore he's not worthy of it and so
that mantle has been passed to somebody
else now here's the deal when it comes
to Thor you have to you have to
recognize that Thor is simply a title
but it's also a name so Thor Odin's son
is how most people refer to him just to
really illustrate the fact that he's the
son of Odin but the best way to look at
it is to simply just refer to him as
Donald Blake because that's what he was
in in the comics that was as alter his
alter ego that was the thai enter that
was the the i guess the nod that Marvel
had done in the first Thor movie do you
ever see that yeah okay so once you put
the name tags sure to said Donald Blake
yeah thats a sultry get whatever he
tries my ex yeah yeah yeah that's it
yeah it's Jane Foster is kind of a she's
an RN character um but the point is is
that Thor is not able to wield the
hammer anymore and that mantle has been
passed to a woman now we don't know who
she is we don't know what her backstory
is we don't know any of that stuff all
we know is that she is the new Thor so
don't think of it as though Thor's had
like a sex change or Thor has like a
document of a woman it simply means that
there is a
there now that wields the power of Thor
now the question is was this a good move
by Marvel and I think it was a terrible
move and the reason why is because
Marvel said that they want to build up
this element of having like a prominent
female superhero and the Marvel
community and they rationalize that by
saying that the big three you know as
far as they considered it was Captain
America Iron Man and Thor where they got
iron man that whole thing I have no
earthly clue but that's what they
established the big three in Marvel
Comics all right they wanted a female
version of one of those three to play a
prominent role of one of those three but
I think that was a stupid idea because
there are so many female characters out
there right now in Marvel Comics I just
don't get a whole lot of recognition or
they're just isolated so like supporting
characters miss marvel is a perfect
example miss marvel is a character they
could have easily elevated to the front
lot and you know how they could have
done that like what they could have done
is they could have taken sky from agents
of shield you ever watched that show
yeah okay Scott from agents of shield
was basically healed using pre DNA
because we would assume that was a Kree
that was in the in that pod that brought
back there was used to bring back
Coulson alright if they had said that
sky is going to be miss marvel her
name's not Carol Danvers but she'll be
miss marvel that would have immediately
raised the popularity of miss marvel and
people would have been like okay and
agents of shield agents of shield yeah
okay we got to find out who this miss
marvel is we got to talk about this
character we got to talk about you know
why isn't she named Carol Danvers and
yet a day on and so on and so forth but
nonetheless they would have taken a
female character in Marvel Comics who
for the most part since her inception
her in first introduction in the Marvel
Comics has played the role of a
supporting character and immediately
elevator like two are like a frontline
character but they didn't do that they
made Thor chick and you know this is
it's silly to me like it's a silly idea
do I think that women need more
representation of Marvel Comics of
course and they're definitely to be more
like prominent female characters in
marvel comics but Marvel's had that
chance all along well husband has had
that opportunity with so many female
characters all along like you had she
hold she hook was a member of the
Fantastic Four she hoped was a member
The Avengers she-hulk had her own own
comic books but model never did a whole
lot with it they never made her like a
front main line character even when she
was part of the Fantastic Four she was
basically just like throwing stuff
around she was like the hired help by
the hired muscle and that's how they
treated her and if Marvel really wanted
to make female characters more prominent
and draw in the the woman reader that's
interested in Marvel Comics then they
should have taken one of these
characters that already exists that has
a backstory that they don't need to make
and made her a prominent character and I
mean that was a problem with miss marvel
when she was part of the Avengers ms
marvel really was useless as part of the
Avengers I mean sure she was strong and
she does some cool stuff but for the
most part she was just the person they
said oh my god Captain America the bad
guys are coming and everybody would
fight and that's it and it really kind
of sucked that they made her that way so
to me I agree with the idea that there
needs to be a stronger female character
in Marvel Comics but I think that making
Thor woman was the wrong way to go
because now they've got to create a
backstory for this character now they've
got to bring up and it make sure that
the continuity remains relatively
consistent not only that I guarantee at
times going to come when Thor's going to
be able to wield his hammer again and so
now what's this chicken I do like what
role is she gonna play so oh I don't
know what was what was the thing with a
Z bill that the horse creature that gets
part of those bars ya later no beta ray
bill can wield Thor's hammer but I mean
that's not in that's what he was Muslim
Owen huh in assignments and I'm this
they fight side by side and I think Odin
gave him his own hammer that's maybe not
quite as powerful but yeah he has a
hammer that's comparable to the powers
of Thor but or to the hammer of Thor but
the fact is like he was he's one of the
very few people who was actually able to
wield Thor's hammer but but the question
has to be asked here is why is it the
Skrull as worthy of wielding Thor's
hammer who is she what's the story
behind er I mean Marvel could come out
and say this is Jane Foster and people
would just be like oh my god really that
sets yeah that's what what we don't know
yet is what Marvel's going to
with it yeah and but oven even then like
like I said I'm looking a big picture
here and the problem here is you have
Marvel that's created this strong female
character I mean she has the powers of
four so she is a man as strong as
anybody is going to be in the Marvel
Comics she can wield Thor's hammer which
means she has a one-up on virtually
everybody in the Marvel Comics because
there's really only a handful of people
looking even wield force hammer to begin
with so right off the bat she's
immediately been elevated to one of the
most prominent characters and Marvel
Comics now everybody wants to know
what's the big picture here what's
Marvel looking at are they really going
to remove the male version of 4 from
this picture whatsoever and being able
to wield the hammer of Thor though we're
still going to be there he's still going
to be able to has a battle action he's
still going to be a prominent character
he still going to have all the powers of
an S Guardian he's going to have
physical you know super strength and all
kinds of good stuff the difference here
is he's just not going to be able to
wield his hammer so are they going to
reintroduce that element eventually are
they going to say okay Thor Odin's son
can wield his hammer again and this girl
is just going to be are they just going
to relegate her to yet another position
of a supporting character and that's why
i say i think was a terrible idea for
them to make this decision because you
already have women characters and marvel
comics that are well established that
having great histories and they have
great origin stories but Marvel's not
going on like they're strong characters
too yeah I'll be this marvelous they
have they have both physical abilities
and they're not just bimbos yeah like
Miss Marvel has somehow basically like
has the powers of Superman in Marvel
Comics she's not nearly as strong as
Superman not by a long shot but the fact
is is that she can fly she has super
strength she gonna do all these really
really cool things and they're just not
really doing anything with her character
I mean she's a she's extremely durable
and so on and so forth and like I said
they couldn't easily turned sky into
miss marvel and immediately elevated the
prominence of miss marvel in the marvel
comics because people would have wanted
to know more about her I mean she's had
solo series here and there they've been
short run but you know I think that this
was a terrible decision by Marvel to
you have a female version of Thor when
they could have easily just taken
characters that people already love and
made them prominent characters on Marvel
Comics I don't know alright so back to
the comments I suppose so I says let's
see you back from where I left off new
miss marvel is a great female character
though she's actually really well down
in the comics are pretty fun a full
Stormbreaker and get her own hammer ah
hey that's what I would think and you
know i would think that maybe Odin or
somebody else powerful would give her
her own weapon but like you said it it
really doesn't matter if they it matters
what they do with her character yeah you
know it doesn't matter if she has the
same power sat or not it matters is is
she going to be a strong character
that's in the forefront or is she just
going to you know disappear into the
background or just become another
character that's in the background yeah
I think it's what'll happen I think this
should be a strong a super strong
prominent character in Marvel Comics for
like six months to a year and then
people then Marvel will be like okay we
got to bring Thor Odin's son back and so
maybe they'll give her her own hammer
but the fact is is that at the end of
the day she's not going to be a unique
character in and of herself to
understand would just be a copy of an
existing character and that's not what
Marvel needs if they want to create a
strong female character in Marvel Comics
right we need to create a character
where people were especially like
younger kids younger guys are going to
look at her and say she's a copy of that
guy it's going to take away from the
idea of having a strong female character
in Marvel Comics they need to create a
character that already have our user
characters already has a unique
backstory is already interesting that's
why I keep pointing to miss marvel or
she hulk and they need to say this
character already is already established
Marvel Comics we're just going to
elevate her and make
a more prominent character issue was
before yeah so I Tara says not a hundred
percent on this I haven't rewatched
agents of shield but i think i remember
it saying that i choose a self-assigned
alias maybe i ringing any bells yep I
don't know bra top my head I got to go
back and rewatch Susan 12 recall but
they could still potentially give her
powers they just have to develop over
time I mean the one thing about our line
is that the marvel cinematic universe
takes place in what we would consider to
be an alternate reality of the main
Marvel Comics so the characters for the
most part remain the same but they may
be entirely different people yeah I mean
like like ultimate spider-man like you
have Peter Parker but then eventually
Miles Morales takes over the role of
spider-man so the character spider-man
still there he's just played by a
different person mm-hmm oh and i forgot
to mention this but somebody had a
pretty interesting perspective about how
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I or wait
no no it was about Earth X and paradise
X in that hole alternate timeline um
they were turning the current 616
universe into that universe with the the
you know female Thor and a couple other
things I'd have to look back in the chat
yeah but as you haven't read like your
ex paradise x series or any of that
stuff on it I didn't want you yeah but
again again I collect hard covers and
that's one of those hard covers that's
far out of print and it's like three
hundred dollars or something ridiculous
like that and I just like I'm waiting
for a reprint I think dude go out and
try to find like mint condition covers
of like old-school comics like like for
example um Franklin Richards first
appeared in the Fantastic Four annual
issue number six and nine
aight i think that coming sells for two
hundred and twenty dollars so yeah good
luck trying to clean I mean finding one
of those that's in mint condition is is
going to be stupid difficult to you and
if you do you're gonna pay through the
nose for it oh speaking of those that
are worthy can a falcon wield Thor's
hammer I'm assuming like Captain America
I mean all right so let's talk about
this let's talk about Falcon taking over
the role of Captain America okay so
Phil's of you that are following the
Civil War storyline we're going to spoil
the hell out of house civil war ends for
the most part so civil war ends with
well man I don't even know ask him acid
you guys want me to ruin the end of
civil war because do it um that I was
just saying yeah like cap because what
happens with the captain america
directly ties into how civil war ends so
if we're going to talk about Falcon
taken over the role of Captain America
we could but we'll end up spoiling civil
war because I have a feeling that
they're gonna do it the way it was it
was done in the comment I think we've
talked about that in the past on the
podcast Rob well that's think most
people know what happens because it was
it well for one thing it was highly
publicized when it did happen that's
true that's true okay and it's pretty
common knowledge at this point what
happens to Captain America at that point
in time well some of my fans have not
read or know about Civil War and I don't
want to ruin it for them but ok so
spoiler alert if you don't want it it's
stopped watching or mute us for like
another 10 minutes and then unmute us
yeah how's that sound that sounds good
enough to me oh alright so I'm not sure
how like want to do this in the comics
in Captain America issue number whatever
was um Captain America gets assassinated
alright they've already introduced
Sharon Carter to us and Sharon Carter is
the one that do deals the killing blow
now she was being hypnotized by dr.
faustos and a ruse that he had going on
with red skull and so on and so forth
Nick Fury is behind everything like he's
talking to Bucky Barnes as they're
watching all this go on and their goal i
think is to break Captain America loose
but nonetheless Sharon Carter like I
think crossbones shoots him initially
Sharon Carter runs up on him and shoots
him in the stomach but she doesn't
realize she was the one that did it it's
not until the end of this it's I'm sorry
it's the death of Captain America issue
number one and it's not until the end of
that comic that one of the minions of
dr. Faust as I came aboard her name is
tells says something to Sharon Carter
that causes her to remember what it was
that happened I think she actually says
dr. Foster says remember and she recalls
the fact that she was the one that shot
captain america now after Captain
America is killed because in the comics
and in that comic like he died
supposedly off screen and off panel and
it's actually like we learned in the
news that he was confirmed have been
killed when he gets to the hospital but
bucky barnes takes over the role of
Captain America for a while and that's
my question are they going to flip are
they going to substitute those two and
if they did then what was the point of
introducing the winter soldier because
the whole element of bucky barnes on the
Winter Soldier was that it was his
return to Marvel Comics it was just kind
of redemption from all the horrible
things that he had done when he was the
Winter Soldier and then he supposedly
makes up for it or really kind of I
guess solidifies himself as the premier
good guy by playing the role of Captain
America
and so I don't know how they're going to
do that are they going to have Captain
America killed I mean is we already have
crossbones we already have Sharon Carter
so the stage is set for the most part
some kind of maybe the Red Skull returns
you know whatever it doesn't happen to
take place but Sharon Carter shoots and
kills Steve Rogers and so I guess Falcon
would take over the role of Steve Rogers
but I don't know how they're going to do
that in the model Cinematic Universe and
I'm afraid that in all honesty they're
going to do in the way that stupid but I
mean I don't know remember as I was
reading that they were going to just
kill off a bunch of the characters in
age of Ultron like Iron Man was gonna
die or commit suicide i frickin Captain
America was gonna get killed by Ultron
uh just almost like a complete wipe so
they could start over they were going to
have somehow like the female version of
Thor take over for for the actor that's
playing Thor Chris Hemsworth it was just
gonna be almost like a complete wipe in
age of Ultron but like I don't see that
happening because that's just way too
extreme and some of these actors still
have contracts yeah you know like I
don't think they would do a complete
wipe yet cuz I also looked into a little
bit of the contracts and apparently the
only person who was exempt from this is
Robert Downey jr. at this point because
he had to be re-signed and everything
after all of this got you know really
popular with with the entirety of comic
book movies but yeah uh apparently the
standard Marvel Cinematic Universe
contract is six movies Wow and of course
after those six movies an actor can
choose to renew for another six movies
or opt out and Marvel can literally call
you in and say hey you have to have
either cameo in this movie or you have
to be the main role in this movie but
you have to reversion robson six points
yeah
okay well um I mean robert downey jr's
got his contract for the most part i
mean he was an Iron Man 1 he had a cameo
in the Incredible Hulk he was in iron
man 2 iron man 3 The Avengers that's
five so ages of Ultron will give him six
so it may be that healed that after this
is done he'll die well I I heard that he
he had a contract for less than that to
begin with because he was he was one of
the first people signed into the
Cinematic Universe yeah that was so like
I mean they they probably weren't
planning on it absolutely exploding like
this and then you know a bunch of movies
being made when he was signed originally
so I think he got resigned for up to
Avengers 3 in Iron Man 4 I mean autos
we're gonna make an Ironman for them
well I've heard a couple different
things I've heard that they're waiting
to make it until phase 3 after age of
Ultron um I've heard that they're
waiting all the way up until phase 4 and
they're gonna try to you know rii sign
him again for for Avengers 3 um so I
don't know I would say the Captain
America 3 is probably when Steve Rogers
will be killed I mean captain america 2
we had the introduction of Falcon and
I'm sure that in some capacity he'll be
in Avengers or Avengers 2 but here's the
deal if you're going to have Falcon if
you're going to have Sam Wilson take
over the role of Captain America then
it's gonna have to be done in a way to
where people want to see him do that so
they're gonna have to build as character
up they're gonna have to make him more
than simply a sidekick because in
Captain America 2 let's be honest he was
a sidekick for Captain America I mean
there was some care to development but
we don't know his backstory in the comic
books we don't know his origins we don't
know how he became Falcon all we know is
that he just took on the wings and that
was it I mean we don't know what led him
to you know being where he was and
Marvel Cinematic Universe so at least if
we do we don't know it on the same level
that we do with Captain America we had a
whole movie dedicated to learning about
Captain America about Steve Rogers
becoming captain america and so that's
one of the reasons I think like Captain
America 2 came off so good because it
was a movie that had the development of
Steve Rogers by chris evans and then his
role in avengers and so then you have
Captain America 2 which deals with like
modern-day hot-button political issues
and the movie was just wild sizes do it
there's a lot of espionage and that
movie too yeah man like it was just so
it was a wildly successful Phil I I
thought it was an amazing movie and so
if they're going to have Sam Wilson play
the world of Captain America than one of
course Steve Rogers is going to have to
be killed off or he's somebody just
going to have to retire I mean I don't
see Steve Rogers retiring and saying I'm
walking away from all this I see him
being killed off I see him dying so the
question is how is Steve Rogers going to
die and who's going to be the one to
kill him I mean it could be Ultron but
that'd be a little lackluster to be
honest it'd be too predictable and the
old man shows up Tony Stark is as I
understand it from the information I've
seen Tony Stark is going to be the one
that creates Ultron so Tony Stark makes
Ultron I guess by accident but you know
unintentionally and this results in
Ultron's programming may be going awry
or something like that maybe he still
develops the Oedipus complex except now
is geared towards Tony Stark and then
you see that he runs amok he goes crazy
a lot of people are fighting him to
Scott at which Hawkeye so on and so
forth Captain America dies in the fray
maybe he sacrifices himself in some
great big honorable way I'm not really
sure but all that stuff is too
predictable and I'm afraid that Marvel
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is going
to go with predictable and I'm hoping
they don't do that i'm hoping they go
with unpredictable i'm hoping the
captain American everybody all those
guys for the most part the first tier
characters make it out alive from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and you know
he ends up being killed in Captain
America 3 he's assassinated by
crossbones or something like that or
maybe it's the end of age of Ultron that
he gets killed by crossbones I don't
know but either way it's interesting so
I mean aside from a statement on the
daily show who has this been confirmed
by like
Marvel has a whole like kevin was on The
Daily Show it wasn't on the dealership
well you know I I was wondering who was
on it like who was the person cuz i
forget i read it yesterday and i read
over it quick and then I kind of got
back to reading this yeah you know like
a all right so Marble Mountain so you
don't have like so you don't have like
black panther the black metal i am from
Council vignette I'm not sure that might
be in the other book I didn't really
read too heavily into what issues were
actually in here because there's
actually captain america issue in here
and a couple other characters are in
here so it could be in the book that's
on its way now that was the kind of
thing from the house of m is when
Captain America when Steve Rogers never
became captain america he's just a
really old guy who lives in like the
slums I guess and a new work and that
was that was interesting to me because
we already had a story like his story
was being built and I personally thought
that that was one of the best written
stories of the entire house of m event
but as for those of you guys who have a
red house of him Steve Rogers never
becomes captain america in the house of
an event he actually he gets out of
World War two alive he marries Peggy
Carter they're married for a few years
and then divorce and he's just an old
man living by himself and when Layla
Miller who is this girl that can see
into alternate realities again can know
and knows it like the house erdem
reality is not right when she starts
waking people up to the fact that the
reality is wrong they go and initially
try to enlist captain america with and
they see he's just a really old guy and
they're like well I mean he's not gonna
be able to do yeah so let's just a mean
yeah the captain america issue i think
there might actually been two issues in
here there's odds over like three three
or four three yeah it might have been
but they read really fast so i could
have just flown to four of them without
even known but it's really cool because
it actually uh describes how like house
of them came to be
like how they took over and it's it that
was really interesting to me how Nick
Fury train Wolverine but like secretly
they hated each other and AH you know
cool stuff like that happened to UM so
now this was a really interesting book
because I think it gave more of the
backstory of the entire universe that
would happen rather and I kind of just
having the perspective of Oh flash
happened and all of a sudden like all
this stuff is different Oh like this
does a thing like but apparently it was
Joe casada always was a the colbert
report well if he says it is true yeah
like he's pretty high up so Wow alright
so so the Falcon is gonna take over for
Captain America man I want to know how
this is gonna happen cuz I'll know like
you took it back like really fast but I
know you you didn't really care for
Falcons character no I did not was there
static I just happen I I took it back as
my subs are just like screaming at me
like my family they were like Rob what
is your problem like the Falcon was
awesome all right in the comics Falcon
is a great character he's a great n
death character with a problem here is
that we don't have decades of Sam Wilson
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe we
have widely with him in it so far and
even then there wasn't a whole lot of
character development in that movie for
the most part he's just like hey captain
america i love what you're doing and I'd
look I don't be my little girl I think
they might really develop him during age
of Ultron like he might become a central
character during that movie but that's
that's a problem that's the problem when
it comes when it comes to me like that
it's like Avengers like a lot of people
complain that there was no character
development and Avengers where there
wasn't supposed to be all the character
development I've been done in there solo
films why would I gotta love characters
oh yeah I mean you've got I mean the age
of Ultron is going to be the development
of Ultron like they're gonna I mean
unless they choose to go the spider-man
3 route and just have like all these
characters stories going on at one time
which was a total
grew up I think that Sam Wilson will be
a character that will slowly develop I
think that we we got him in Captain
America too I think that he may have
cameos or discussions and other events
he might even appear in agents of shield
season 2 I think that will get a little
bit of character development and
avengers age of ultron will learn some
more about and maybe a little bit of a
back story or something like that or why
I mean somebody's going to say why are
you even a superhero you know what's
your deal or something like that and
we'll get a little bit of backstory
about about him being young and so on
and so forth and then and then I think
in Captain America 3 is when Captain
America will die where Steve Rogers will
die and he'll take over the role of
Captain America and we'll have that
entire movie to learn more about the
Falcon to learn more about yeah well so
as a character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it makes sense to me anyway
actually I don't know it it seems like
Captain America you know Chris Evans
really wants out though like make sense
what is the uh what people say in the
comments they have any information that
we do not um they're partying like with
with each other about Earth acts and
implanted X and paradise X okay it's a
little camera thwart on epic and iron
man in that story would actually be cool
if they tied into Planet X the story
with Miles Morales going to tie into the
civil war storyline no my lads came on
after civil work well in isn't he's not
the actual amazing spider-man is he he's
an ultimate spider-man ya know he's yeah
he's the ultimate version of Peter
Parker yeah um what you guys think about
superior iron man i haven't you have a
recipe Rihanna man
out ya nah know you would that I need to
get into the most recent Iron Man comics
the problem see the problem is this so i
doing all these Marvel explain videos
like I don't usually have time to like
read current comics so it's like hey
guys here's what happened in Marvel
Comics like 20 years ago but I need to
get caught up you're not eat the death
of Tony Stark oh you gonna die and you
know what I bet I bet I know how Tony
sagres gonna die at the hands look at
your your mic is a little quiet still
compared to mine my mic as well my mic
is a little quiet took them all this
time to mention that yeah okay it's so
here's here's that thing is the question
mm-hmm I'm trying to wear this right
what he said I think was a really good
idea or a really good point to touch on
when you were talking about how you
think they're like a whole bunch of
characters are going to be killed off
relatively secure and in Avengers age of
Ultron and they're going to go from
there because the problem that we have
here is models introducing characters
with established characters so we have
Quicksilver in the Scarlet Witch coming
up as far as I understand that the
Inhumans are going to play a role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they're going
to up here at some point along the way
there's characters that Marvel doesn't
have the rights to right now that of
course they can't include the x-men all
the other versions of the x-men so we're
talking about characters like sinister
apocalypse people like that marble
doesn't have the rights to any of that
stuff so all the characters that are
involved in or that are part of the
x-men universe are not going to be in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so like
Nate gray X man from the age of
apocalypse he won't be in in any of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe films so the
Fantastic Four won't be there I think
mobile made a terrible terrible mistake
by selling these rights off to other
studios but nonetheless um we're not
going to see a lot of this stuff going
on so if they don't kill awesome
characters things are going to become
incredibly convoluted
like we're gonna have some major event
ago later on down the road we're gonna
have like 90 people fighting together I
mean not even though huh so here's
another thing Rob since since you you
are starting to get swayed over to this
viewpoint I remember a time two weeks
ago when you said that they were just
gonna recast everybody i said no such
thing I think you did and then Benny
started to somewhat agree with you well
I mean if they wanted to keep the
element of Iron Man and Captain America
I mean that would be the only way to go
they wanted to keep the element of Steve
Rogers as Captain America and they want
to keep the element of Tony Stark as
Iron Man then yes they would have to
because i guarantee that neither Robert
Downey jr. Chris Evans or even Chris
Hemsworth are going to want to be
playing these comic book characters you
know sever ever yeah they don't want to
be ya 10 years from now they don't want
to be playing Iron Man or Captain
America or Thor so um here's another
interesting thing as they were talking
about who is going to take over for iron
man when when our DJ wanted out and it's
either going to be rescue which I would
assume would be pepper potts or it's
going to be war machine I would say it's
gonna be war machine because there was a
point to calm I didn't when Rhoades was
iron man like he did play the character
of iron man so I mean eventually Tony
Stark came back and roads went back to
be more machine but I I think that makes
the most sense that Don title will take
a little role of here's here's my issue
with that is does Don Cheadle have the
ability to design that Tony Stark does
to design new suits and adapt the suit
to new conditions like you know outer
space and really cold temperatures and
like anything that he might confront in
the future where iron man just destroyed
all his suits and you know his servers
where he stored all his research and
stuff
an iron man 3 is that mantle gonna be
passed some hours Tony Stark just
flat-out gonna die well that's hand saw
somebody else take over that isn't as
capable well that's why 20 * came back
in the comics because it was it was
silly and it wasn't believable like
James Rhodes was a great great iron man
the problem is he just he's not a genius
engineer right he's a military guy you
know he's a friend of tony stark and so
it didn't make any sense that he would
be able to continue the mantle of iron
man long-term because he can't do not he
can't design new suits he can't sit down
in engineer new suits he can use
existing technology for whatever goal
that he wants to use it for but in the
world of Marvel Comics like technology
moves super fast especially when you
have my super advanced technological you
know places like what Conda or you have
like Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
who has his whole future probability
room or whatever is where he writes down
all these equations about like how
stuff's going to turn out so you know
James Rhodes I think would be a great
great iron man for the short term but I
don't know how they would do it in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe i would say
that Tony Stark will be a character that
they would have to either have operate
off screen and new suits just get made
all the time I 20 start but you just
never seen in the movies or yeah they're
gonna have to recast when they start
when Robert Downey jr. decide sleeve now
another thing is the consideration for
pepper potts and not not necessarily
that she's going to get really insanely
smart and ingenious and in the next few
movies but she in the position she is in
Tony Stark's company right now could
potentially have other people work for
her secretly and develop new suits for
her when she becomes iron man if she
becomes Iron Man or iron woman for
rescue there were characters out there
that were smart and had an intelligence
that was
reasonably close to Tony Stark's but
there was only one Tony Stark and even
now like even in the current version
Tony Stark is still iron man so there's
been a couple people that have popped up
here and there and taking his place but
there's no at least far as I know he's
still iron man there's no there's really
no one else that plays iron man besides
Tony Stark because that's that's kind of
the that's one of the problems i think
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is going
to run into you've got a guy who's a
genius who can design all forms of
technology and who can create these
super amazing iron man suits for
virtually any condition as long as he
knows how to do it everybody else around
him is not nearly as smart as he is I
mean happy Hogan is like a dumb boxer in
the and the marvel cinematic universe
which is disappointing because Jon
Favreau is an amazing actor and happy
Hogan was a pretty useful character in
the comics he was a really cool guy he
wasn't I mean he was the i guess like
the personal assistant for Tony Stark
but he wasn't like he wasn't the way
he's depicted in the in the moves right
now oh no no they could they could
change anything in that regard I mean
they could find a way to make him
smarter and I think in in iron man 3 he
was he was a little bit hey I know he
kind of had his dumb moments but he was
he was a little bit more valuable to
tony stark in iron III than he was and
in I think to and I think he had minimal
part in wanted me like he was just look
at Reiver and there's pretty much that
seemed where Tony Stark drove himself
and happy was like waiting for him and
he like somehow caught up with him and
it was like oh you know driving yourself
while use mine like that was pretty much
the extent of his character that was
really that was really about it when it
came to a happy Hogan in the first movie
but I mean you've got like pepper pots
and pepper potts is not I mean unless
she's hiding some sort of genius-level
intellect that no one knows about she's
not gonna be able to engineer stuff that
the way 20 ladies she's very close to
iron man in his design process though
that's true but just because
she sees somebody designed something
doesn't mean that she actually knows had
it i mean there's with the iron man
suits they're so intricately designed
and so advanced there's not as though
she's painting a picture like she has
like she's not she's not molding a
sculpture like you know you're you're
talking about where Tony Stark assembles
the pieces of the clay in such a way
that he's able to create this very
intricate and specific Iron Man suit and
then he had pepper potts who would show
up and just like make a molding and it
would look like an Iron Man suit but as
soon as you put it on and probably just
like fall apart and like the leg falls
off or something like that I mean I
don't know but you have basically all
these people that surround iron man that
none of them are nearly as smart as he
is now you do have people who are smart
like you've got Justin Hammer you've got
people around him that are intelligent
and could potentially maybe a sister but
at the end of the day none of them are
on the same level as Tony Stark to
intelligence we've been talking about
how they're going to make mutants into
either in humans or miracles yeah I in a
way do they still have the rights to
bring in characters from say the
Fantastic Four like Reed Richards so my
god not have originated like the
Fantastic Four originated nope so my
gosh indian is that a fantastic for
don't belong to them so they came along
and they said well we have this guy
named stretcho and this day named
invisible minh and a guy named the flame
well I'm not even saying he has that
abilities because part of his
availabilities originated in his origin
story and from what I understood they
just couldn't call the x-men x-men they
had to call them something different and
have them originated different so like
I'm not even saying Reed Richards and in
the Cinematic Universe would have to
have stretching abilities he could just
be a really smart guy who somehow ends
up taking over for iron man eventually I
mean you could like if you read future
foundation of the Fantastic Four like
you get a lot of insight into the
relationship between Reed Richards at
his dad methane
richards and so you learn that even at a
young age I Reed Richards was super
smart and he talked about that what is
that he talks about how all the other
kids around him are different because
compared to him they're all dumb because
he's just so much smarter than all of
them and so even like even the young
ages intellect was just genius level and
so you could have some genius prodigy
that comes along and Marvel says well
this is Reed Richards but not really you
know there's nae hella they're saying in
the comments uh Hank Pym could take over
uh no dr. doom means no Avengers AI
storyline but I don't like i like i said
i don't i don't know if they would have
the rights to use that the characters
the same way or not like Victor Von Doom
the doombots all that stuff none of
that's going to be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe unless the whites are
given back but Fantastic Four is being
rebooted in 2016 I think it is so that's
not those rights aren't coming back
anytime soon barna was already building
his own Iron Man suits whose are no or
no yeah ara uh Jarvis did the labor
Jarvis is apparently going to develop
into Ultron that'll be cool now that
that that is actually something that I
hadn't thought of twenty start initially
like he designed the physical suits but
Jarvis has as long as Jarvis exists the
era Shania's olean automated process
yeah I mean it is but I mean how
elaborate would the improvements be
though I mean Pepper Potts you just say
Jarvis design me a suit that can allow
me to fly through space like an oxygen
tank might take a little longer but it
might yeah it happened because Jarvis is
like an assistant like he actually makes
decisions for iron man he he does
calculations that that Tony Stark
doesn't have have the time to do yeah
all that stuff so yeah I mean it's
interesting you know here
is I'm curious to see what direction the
marvel cinematic universe will go if
they choose to kill off some of the more
prominent characters right now they're
really talking about Planet X they're
like if tony is the only genius then it
will be a planet x feel to it yeah I
need to read up on our section planet x
yeah I i really i really haven't read it
either so yep later guys look into
planted it all right um nothing we're to
go ahead and wrap this podcast up I
think that makes sense um what are you
gonna upload a new video man man I've
been taking forever but I've been
getting called into work left and right
yeah like they just don't they don't get
how important youtube is at work unlike
their just their call they're calling me
in like a bunch of people because we're
short-staffed at work like we've only
got five people working I'm like serving
everybody repairing computers checking
in computers so like we need to hire
more people it's kind of like what
happened when that guy went off on
vacation or got sick at your work how
you were working all those crazy hours
oh yeah well I mean people were doing it
too because I was off for ten days so
that's just let me have it goes I mean
it's a lot over time which is cool and
everything but sometimes you catch your
breath but I'm making a lot of money but
the video names people know what comics
it yes so what I'm what I'm thinking is
I'm just gonna shoot all of the like
b-roll footage and everything for for
the rest of my videos so i have that
andy and then i can just I I can just
record myself talking about it kind of
like i did with with the last video i
put up i had b-roll of you know you know
all the different shots of the book
itself and opening it up and all that
stuff so if i get all of that out of the
way at once that's a huge portion of the
work that it takes all my camera and get
get all the books into you know the
right position and you know go about
timing myself out right
so I should be able to get all that done
for everything at once which would make
it a lot easier to just make the videos
later that make sense um well I mean as
I told you guys of course we're going to
be finishing up the Civil War we should
have the whole series finished by Monday
and after that I think I'm gonna take a
break for about a week or so maybe play
some call of duty like live stream some
call of duty hopefully I can play with
loyal patriot that guy's pretty hustle
modernist stream so i hope like i will
be able to play with him and then we're
going to do franklin richards and then
we're going to do Jean Grey and then I'm
not sure we're going to do after that so
but um but yeah so I guess maybe Benny
and solidly with us next week you said
you're going to be gone next week yeah
I'm gonna be gone so i'm not gonna be
here next week either but for the next
two or three weeks after that i should
have a lot of time so well that'll be
cool maybe be able to be recovering from
surgery so um but yeah so uh I guess
we'll catch you guys later see you